Được mười sẽ đàn nhiều, thì thì là ở linh mình đánh mình ở đó thọng
Ninh mình mình nghĩ xưa của nó mình, sông hà nằm, sông linh mình góc
Đi đó thọng, mình các bạn để này nếu mà cho đi này thì chất hình linh mình đánh dậy mười
Tại tin vậy
Chúng là các bạn sẽ sẽ đánh nó khi các bạn nghiệp nhiều đi trường dở
Đặc biệt này này cho dở thành đây, thật chỉ là trong cái cùng này thì nó có để hình yên
Đi đây là để thị dậy hình
Thế cú khá bất ngờ vì để này không có xong xuất
Nếu bạn ở đây có đàn xử, cho mình để kìm chắc chắc chắc chắc chắc chắc chắc chắc chắc chắc chắc chắn
Để này không để bỏ xong xuất nhé
Chúngy hồi xuất và thập chỉ tích phần ở đây 2 câu
còn như thế
Có lâu cái tơ có này